each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available okay so let's get started uh
hello everyone uh it's is my pleasure to
introduce T and Eric from the University
of
Washington uh even though they are still
students but uh they are working on very
cool project uh a depl in toet a very
popular depl in toet in the open source
world called
mxnet and uh for your information Chi is
also the main author of another very
popular open source machine learning
package called XT boost for grading uh
boost Tre is
learning so welcome T and Eric to MX or
to give a talk on
mxet okay thanks Ken for the
introduction it's a great pleasure to
give a talk here so today we are going
to mainly talk about mxnet the insights
that we learn from the system and the
mainly what the system dis the
motivation that why we design it and
Eric is going to talk about some T
theorist on usage and advanced use cases
so first I'm going to acknowledge our
collaborators including contributors we
got especially we got two Microsoft
contributors here trint is from
Microsoft research and T who is sitting
on the audience he is now in Microsoft
being image team and they joined us in
the very beginning and uh if you have
questions related to internal staffs you
are more than welcome to ask them if I'm
not appropriate to answer but uh so yeah
and we also want to thank Jacob for for
proposing the buting API which is used
for the uh language understanding and
comes very handy recently so this is the
outline for talk and uh today we're
going to talk about deep learning
systems and as you know there are a lot
of recent deep learning Frameworks each
come with their own unique features can
had a very nice survey about advantage
and disadvantage of all the systems well
maxnet is not yet in one then hopefully
it will be and today I'm going to talk
about uh I want to discuss in you a very
different perspective so all the
existing surveys about this this system
asks the question like how what what are
the nice features of all the systems in
the current stage so let's ask a
different question so let's let's ask
what what is the how will this system
evolve and eventually become given given
the full engineering power and all the
things that you can throw into it
because
uh different system provide different
user interfaces and different user
interfaces will eventually lead to the
limiting the capabilities these are like
booms in those system and The Operators
all those engineering effort are like
Meats in the system so these booms will
eventually result in what's the limit
you can achieve and the inal flexibility
and the and and the and the power of of
those system so today I'm going to talk
about from this
perspective so I'm going to talk about
programming models so so normally if you
think about deep learning or any
programming Lang or any any task in
machine learning you can you need to
program them and that's the interface
you have there are two type programming
models that you can use one type of
programming model is called imperative
programming so here this is the
imperative programming of new P script
that gives you the result of e here
which is a very simple result this is
not a different but as you all know that
Microsoft has a toet called cntk that's
computational neuro computational
Network toet and Google have another
famous framework called tensor flow that
all this operates on those computational
graphs and bear with me this is the
basic task that a different to need to
be able to do efficiently so what
imperative programming does is that what
you do is that you will Implement all
those operations like matrix
multiplication in neuron networks they
will be more complicated things like
convolution and the element wise
addition and the imper imperative
program will do those things what step
by step so you write your program as you
execute this Clause it will basically
translate into a kernel call on GPU or
some CPU
functions on the other hand another more
typical way is actually in most deep
learning platforms is called declarative
programming so in declarative
programming what you do is you first
declare those computations you want and
then you send send those computational
graphs to some compile function or or
other equivalent of compile function
then you will you can utilize those
compiled functions for your result so
the difference between from the imper
programming is that in the decare
programming normally you first declare
all you need then the computation only
happens at the com after you do the
compilations a typical uh example about
declarative programming with uh outside
of deep learning context is SQL for
database which I think many of you might
be familiar with so many the existing
deplo Frameworks also usually use those
declarative programming for example if
you think about configuration file based
framework like cafe or cntk you you
declare a networks that's basically the
declarative part in other Frameworks
like 10 Flor C you use the python API
that's not very different from a
configuration file but more flexible but
gives you a more flexible way of
declaring what those what what those
computation you'll need so what are the
difference between the between the
imperative programming and declar
programming in the context of deep
learning so think about the Deep neuron
networks here this is actually a Sher
neuron Network what declared program
gives you is actually a black box so
usually you declare what other other
computational graphs are here this is
the this is the one layer one layer
neural network then you throw it to the
tool kit and and and tell to Kit give me
a gent and give me the output and and
the and the toolkit is able to gives you
whatever you require on the other hand
if you do imperi programming you need to
you need to write the script layer by
layer basically here you you you you
have some functions called layer 1
forward layer two. forward then you call
back propagation of course in some
popular systems they will do the
wrapping for you so that in the for
example in touch you can you can build
all those configurations and the
imperity part is actually hidden the
code but you can always dig into the
code and hack if you are a good hacker
or researcher because because for any of
the advanced need you need so these are
two programming Styles what are the
difference so one of the thing or one of
the advantage I'm trying to argue for
declared programming first is because
most of Frameworks follow the declared
programming Paradigm including all the
Frameworks you see except for T I guess
in a de planning word so you know the
the declaring the declarative program
are more efficient mainly because they
they allowed to do more optimization
because you you don't need to specify
what procedure you need but instead you
only say what you need so take this for
example so assume that we want to do
this calculation steps the left side is
the imperity program and right side is a
declarative program how many bytes you
need to to calculate the to finish the
calculation basically in a python consel
so in left side we can see that there
are four variables here so and each of
variable takes 10 10 40 1064 bit float
so normally it would take like four four
times the array term uh for four number
of arrays to finish this calculation on
the other hand if you do have a de
program what you can do is like we can
find that the declar program will find
that C and D can actually share the
memory because C is intermediate memory
that does isn't say by the user so you
can kind of optimize out and get three
copies of memory instead of four copies
of memory this might be a very naive
example but it's kind of demonstrate
that the the difference between
declarative and imperative because in
the imper word you specify the
calculation procedure and that might not
be optimal and another key property
about this is that you the impu program
need to be prepared for all the possible
Futures say that you are writing this
program in the python
console the the when you write to this
point actually the imperor program
doesn't know that whether c will be used
in the future or not so it can not
actually directly reuse memory of course
the python gabage collector can kind of
reuse the if it get recycled but this
kind of this is some somewhat Limited in
in the sense of Deering which we will
give a more detailed example in the next
slide so on the other hand in the in the
declarative part when you do the
compilations the the declar program sees
the entire computational graph as well
as the boundaries by boundary I mean
that it see the the the program can see
what are the input and output and what
are the intermediate stages and all
these intermediate stages can not be
seen by the user which means that they
can be freely optimized all be re be
Rewritten or or are doing the memory
memory optimization that we mentioned
earlier so a more realistic example in
the Deep learning word is that is is
about this case study about what's the
memory cost you need to run a un layer
neural network if you only do only want
to do a prediction prediction in a
production environment instead of
training if you do a impr programming
style mod if you do imperal programming
normally what you will do is that you
will do this n forward functions here
and because most of the imper most of
the different Frameworks are optimized
for both forward prediction and back
propagation normally the statistics are
keep in cheack of the in those data
structures so they cannot be
freed and that that's for the same
reason that that because the imper
program need to be prepared for the
possible future of back propagation on
the other hand in the declar program you
decare enti forward forward
computational graph and call compilation
function when the the the compilation
function basically sees the graph and it
knows that all those memories can be
shed in place so when so as a result you
get a much less memory CS when running
when running a declarative program
normally for prediction so normally you
only need two copies of memory that
alternates through each other yes can
you explain why the memory can be shared
from different layers because when you
do back propagation it's ABC uh Bel to
exactly the the reason is that the in
our use case we are only doing
prediction instead of B propagation so
imagine that you in this use case you
only want to do prediction and this
comput this computational graph is not
about uh it's not about it's not about
back propagation so this memory can be
saved that that's that's exactly why
Imperial program kind of cost memory
because it want to be prepared for the
case of B possibility of bad propagation
as well as the possibility of of only
doing forward prediction of course you
can optimize this program by adding
special cases like I only want to do
forward prediction that's adds another
complicate another layer of complication
to the imper program so there are a
bunch of optimization that you can do
for a declarative program because of a
advantage of exist the entire Global
scope of a computational graph instead
of a local step one example is that you
can do dependency pruning in here this
is a forward propagation step and on the
right side is this is the graph
corresponding to the back propagation
step
so this because there's addition here
you can find and the and you can find
that back back propagation actually
doesn't depend on the value of f so this
memory can be freed as early as the
forward propagation step and we don't
need to pre prond that until postpone
that until the back propagation step so
if you only need some intermediate
values of of VAR VAR C you don't need
even to carry out other other
computation as well so this this is kind
of more Advanced version of dependency
pruning that yes you can hard code them
into into your framework but declar
programming can't can't give it free for
you if you have a good
Optimizer another thing that you can do
is operative Fusion so here because say
is a intermediate variable that's not
referenced by the user and you can
easily optimize that all say you you
provide a huge kernel that does the
Matrix M application plus some bi which
is commonly which is commonly available
in many of Frameworks you can do this
kind of operation rewriting to write
this program however you cannot do that
for the same reason because in the
Imperial program there's a possible
future that c might be reference and
there's another optimization that you
can do for example in uh that I mention
that is memory shared in here okay so
I've advocated so much for declar
programming so far and and uh it's good
that many of the existing deep learning
Frameworks actually do follow the the
the use case of declarative programming
a sense that you declare the neural
network then you optimize the
computational structure so why do we
still need imper
programming or otherwise we basically
everything so far is good and we can end
this talk here so why do we still need
imper programming so imagine the same
case for for SQL in the database we all
need to imagine that you want to develop
a web app that need to do a banking
online banking system and you have a
good secq server say Microsoft secq
server and it does all the good jobs for
you with all Cur optimizations gives you
a result quickly and uh but still you
need some front end language like cop
and JavaScript to interactiv with
it so so why why why do why does we web
web developers do this need this front
end language the reason is that we the
declarative language kind are kind of
limited in what they can do and there
are some certain things that declarative
language are not good at take so take
for example you imag that how you can do
a parameter update in in decover
language it's it's possible it's but you
do need to extend the language into some
exent for example T flow need to support
mutations in a comp in a computational
graph which which is not very natural
and requires some engineering effort
into that other more comp more
complicated example include things like
optimizations like limited memory bfgs
stab which requires a l search and and
uh think about like how you can how you
can write a line search program in SQ
which I don't know how to write maybe
there are some some extended language in
the in the in the SQ Dom that that that
can do that and there are other othera
use cases like variable input lens which
are not very easy to be described by a
predetermined comp comput computational
graph and need to be need to be used by
need to be need to be used the advanced
features in the in the imperative
language to to do the dynamic
unrolling so one of the Advan of
emperial program is that it's deeply
embedded into the host language so also
10th flow and siano are claim to to be
supporting in Python actually when you
write tlow orano programs you're
actually writing another program that's
called tlow it's like you you are you
are writing CQ in Python it's it's not
like you are writing python languages
you are writing SQ language so when you
are writing those declar programs in
Python you're actually writing in
context of those declar programs however
if you writing imper programs in Python
you are actually writing in Python
because you can take advantage of all
those Advanced features like you can you
can condition on the data set lines in
here this is a very naive example say I
have two type of neural networks that
that I like to do for for for input data
lens that's bigger than 10 I use first
Ty first type of NE architecture and for
the other other input type I use second
type of architecture if you have an
imperative program you can basically
very easily do the r time dispatching
and select the path that you want there
are more complicated examples for
example you might want to take a look at
output of a neural network and decide
which path you want to go this can be
very common in reinforcements learning
and uh there are the on the case of
recurrent neur neural networks say you
want to do prediction you want to
dynamically unroll your your your
predictions and the length of length of
the of the predicted sequences is not
determined in the beginning of course
all these things can be hardcoded in
your system and and optimized for
specific use cases but to support these
things in a generic version we do need
some flavor of imperitive programming in
order to do that
easily so that's why we want to ad
advocate for a mixed flavor so mxet the
MX in mxet kind of stand for mixed
flavor we want to we want to combine the
power of imperity programming together
with the optimized declar programming so
as we know that as as I hopefully you
are not convinced that the imperial
programming are kind of more flexible
and allows you to write whatever things
you need say you want to insert your
optimization step and your training loop
on the other hand the declared program
can be quite powerful in a sense that A
system can optimize the memory
computation and everything in behind for
you so in MXL we provide two two set of
apis that are coupled together in a
sense that they work together as a as a
whole piece so we have a new like n
interface that basically execute as you
go that's inter that's a imper
programming part and then we have a
symbolic API that basically does the
declar programming
part in the hope uh so this is the
example of basic training Loop in mxnet
so so what what you basically do is like
you write imper ROP here and we have a
dictionary of the from that map string
of key input to the corresponding array
so every iteration what you do is that
you copy input to the corresponding
arrays that's imper step the executor
itself is compiled from a declarative
language so you decare all your neural
networks in those and compile into
executor then you call executor forward
backward this optimized stab that
optimize for memory and then you you use
imperative stab this is a this is the
imperative imperative stab of SGD but we
can definitely put more advanced stab
like like the variance reduction method
that that developed here or uh or other
other other type of optimizers here so
the
re uh the the reason that the the fact
that we're able to use the impov stab
actually helps help us a lot in a sense
that after we released mxet in the
beginning we only have SGD with momentum
optimizers and after a few months many
people contributed other optimizers like
RS prob ALR and all these all these
people are not original develop of the
framework which which make makes which
makes which say which shows that MX is
kind of easier to use in terms of this
imperative programming on the other hand
it's still very efficient in a sense
that all those bottom neck part are
still optimized by those declarative
programming
part another example that's actually
quite exciting for me is that is about
the support for variable lens input or
variable size input in images so
recently uh this is actually thanks to
the proposal of Jacob who is in
Microsoft so as you know if you do if
you do sequence training normally you
have sequence of different lenses and it
usually correspond to different network
structure of different lens or different
shape so thanks to the imperative
execution model that we have actually
this is qu by and he support he added a
support to of the bucketing API which
basically switches by the by the input
lens and use pick different executor for
execution so each of this executor
respond to a different network that for
that specific input and all this fter
can share the memory so according to him
we only cost around timelines of python
code which may be a bit exact toate but
I think I truly believe in him because
this is basically a a a map or switch in
Python and that's all you need to to
support the variable Lance
input so in summary in terms of
programming models hopefully you are not
convinced that there are two style
programming models in different
languages either you can do the clar
programming that's very optimized and
Engineers always always like that it
it's good in production systems on the
other hand imperitive programming gives
you a flexibility of inserting whatever
you need into the into the control flows
and doing round time Dy Dynamic
dispatching of your operations
combination of these two can maximize
your
productivity for for one reason this is
the best thing that I learned from from
my undergrad that's amdas law from
computational comput comput computer
architecture basically it says that you
only want to optimize the botton next in
your system so this is the same for the
Deep
learning usually when we are doing
extensions to a deep learning program or
de learning architecture we extending
the the part that that we extend may not
be the bottom neck of your of your
computation and usually we can put many
of the existing pieces in those
declarative languages and use imper
language to to smoothly add the things
you want to add and still get the
maximum performance you want and that
that is that motivates us to use this
kind of mixed programming design okay so
now we have talk about programming
models another thing that that's very
important is to try to develop a system
that effectively support this two kind
of program model and allows to mix them
together especially in a multiple device
environment as we all know that when you
have a machine now you can put four gpus
into it and uh if if in a Distributing
environment there are even more
resources you can utilize it's very
important to be automatically utilize
all resources to maximize your pro
maximize your performance so however
it's quite painful to write multi string
programs or concurrency programs in uh
although I like them very much but it's
really painful to write especially to
write them for specific cases so one
thing that we did is we have a
dependency tracking engine that
automatically paralyze all operations
for you here's the example so these are
four imperative crosses of of operations
and you can find that these two
operations can run in
parallel and what we what what we
actually have is that we have a generic
dependency engine that would check all
the operations including the imperative
and declarative exclusions to tr them
together and automatically paralyze all
the possible operations you have here's
a more realistic example so this is a
bunch of code that you don't have to
read but basic idea is that this is a
two layer neural network that runs on
two gpus and you need to copy the data
to CPU for synchronization to the and
copy them back so these are the generary
code of a data parallel Paradigm you
have and this is a python code that you
can write actually in
mxet this correspond to this
computational graph and there are many
interesting aspect from this
computational graph so you can find that
there are computational paths on the
left side that's on GPU one on GPU zero
actually and on the right side is the
computation Parts on the GPU one and you
can do a forward backward propagation
and after the first back propagation of
the top layer
as soon as you get a result actually you
can copy the data to the CPU do the
update and copy them back so one of the
important optimization that you want to
do for this kind of computational
Paradigm is that you want to overlap
your computation with the with the
communication so as soon as you get this
result this memory copy can happen and
you can in conly you can do this another
step of back propagation and you can
find a similar pattern in model Paris as
well for example in your multi layer STM
as soon as you get the first time stamp
ready you can directly copy a result the
second GPU can kick off and all the
things can can can start in
concurrently however it's quite hard to
hard code all these patterns and uh do
those asynchronized communication so we
do need a dependent Checker to check all
this imperative declarative operations
one of the key property I want to
emphasize here in in our design of the
of the schedule engine is that it's is
designed to be transparent in a sense
that where we don't want to make
Assumption of what kind of operation
want to schedule and basically it means
that we can schedule anything including
those code that aren't written by us
okay which will Eric will give a more
detailed example actually so however
there are a lot of troubles want when
you want to have such G dependency
engine one of the trouble is that about
memory cycling actually surprisingly so
here is a two dependency paths that you
have two operation that depends on c and
b and then we have a memory deletion
that's automatically triggered by a
garbage
however this memory delection cannot
this memory deletion cannot happen
cannot happen before those operation are
carried out so this is like imp implicit
dependency that you really need to be
able to check another interesting
example is about random number
Generations so here you have two random
number Generations in your in your in
your code it seems that they can run in
parallel however as if you you're
familiar with random number generator
usually you have to run in a Serial
manner either for reproducibility
because every every time you do want to
the same sequence code give you the same
result and because and another reason is
that random number generator is the
result that cannot be sure that Havey
serialized so in order to support this
kind of two kind of operations you
really need to extend those dependency
engine from a
immutable scheduler which is the
technical thing but you which you don't
have you don't have to understand to to
something that supports mutation and in
our framework what we do is that we try
to do things in way so for all all the
possible resources memories random
number generators and all the things we
will allocate a a variable or tag to and
attach them it's like a tag of your of
your bag in the in the flight so attach
them to each of resources and when you
push the operation to the engine you use
this tag to specify what resources you
want to read or muted and engine treat
the operations as a blackbox in a sense
that engine simply use those tag to
track dependency and execute and went
ready but wouldn't actually know what's
in the content of this LDA
function so all these C ex code
execution patterns will be translated to
as synchronized C of these pushes into
dependency engine and you can plug in
arbitary functions in here as well
including the code that you de you
developed here so this is a this is how
this is a huge picture showing how I do
it I'm not going to walk through it but
you can always read it from our blog
post we have a we have a detailed design
doc of of what we did in those systems
basically we have a multiple dispatching
Quee that's that is aware of the read
and right
dependencies so to recap this
section we we really need a good
dependency Checker that checks the check
checks all the dependencies if you want
to build a powerful system for multiple
gpus or multiple resources and having
such dependency engine makes things
easier for you in a sense that you don't
have to hard code all the data
paralyzation patterns and if you want
have a model paralyzing you simply write
the python code in a seral manner and it
will it will it will execute the the
dependent operations as soon as it's
ready and it's ready to use and gives
you the maximum performance and it can
also be used in combination with other
optimization such as data compression
which optimize for the which optimize
the cost of each individual op
individual operations in a sense that
such kind of dependency Checker have
helps you to run more things in current
in a concurrent manner okay I mentioned
two major motivations for us to to build
a system we want to mix the programming
model to for maximum prod for maximum
optimization and the and flexibility and
we have built the dependent scheduling
engine to schedule arbitary operations
so that you can you can make arbitrary
parition pattern more easier and I I'm
going to briefly walk through other
features that might be of interest but
uh yeah so mxl2 comes with low memory
consumption mainly because we have those
declarative optimization but optimize
memory so as example one one of our
friend actually chains a entire image
net data set on a single single machine
with four GTX 9 9 900 90 980 GPU which
is not a very good GPU because we
because we can we can use less memory
than the existing system so we can fit
bigger neur networks into a into a into
those bad cards it's more it's also
lightwe and pable in a sense that it's
it's available in all the possible
languages and the major platforms and
it's also available in Windows of course
and uh uh it you you can find in all the
mobile devices and one interesting thing
that we encourage you to check out is we
have a
JavaScript version which means that
which actually runs in your browser so
if you if you if you can open this link
now if you have a laptop and there's
image classification that demon that
runs on your browser and the Microsoft
do have an advantage here in a sense
that Microsoft age actually runs I think
eight time faster than Chrome because
they didn't optimize for the for the
asm.js part but so this is really due to
the fact that we are really we make
things really posable in a sense that
all dependencies are minimized and we
can we can compile the entire project
into one file and compile the into
JavaScript and this does the JavaScript
use the same
backand code with it used the same
backhand code yes so C++ yes exactly uh
so it's it's a technique called
inscription that compiles that compil C+
C++ code into JavaScript but you do need
to isolate all the dependencies in in
order to to be able to do that and this
comes very handy when you run demos for
example if you have a new model that you
want to show to your colleagues
basically you can run a demo on the
blowser and you don't need to have a
dedicated server for whatever purposes
and it also runs on major Cloud
platforms we have a building support for
AWS S3 and I think that's a ongoing Pro
request on supporting Azure integration
as well and it runs on major major
scheduling engine such as MPI srid
engine and Hado
y so this is the comparison of single CP
single GPU Vision task I think a major
takeaway of this slide is that also we
support mixed style of pro of Imperial
programming and the and security
programming we are as efficient as all
the major system because all the we sh
all the same kernels and all the things
and Ms is really well optimized for
those Inception style or residual N
Style architecture that have multiple
paths which gives us a much much more
memory saving than the existing
Frameworks and we have a new
optimization that's able to further
optimize another factor of 2 over
three using using the graph rewriting
techniques and and uh here's a
comparative example about forward only
computation and forward plus backward
which answers your question in the
previous you know which answers the
previous question about like why forward
computation gives you like cost less
memory simply because there are less
memory dependencies and you can save
more in a forward competition as
compared to the forward plus backward
competition and declar programming gives
that for you on the other hand imper
programming also gives you all the power
that you need to to write your research
code EAS and parts in into the
productive
environment this is the entire overview
of the
system basically it's it's kind of very
different from an existing system
because we think it we we build it in a
way such that we want have undd module
to spot Imperial programming as well as
the symbolic excution model to support
declar programming okay so I think I
finished all the overview about the
system and the general idea behind the
system here are some takehold messages
that you want to
that that I hopefully that you can get
from this talk so from my part of talk
and Eric will will give some tutorials
about the detail usages so MX stands for
mixed programming and maximum prod
productivity to MX and uh one of the
important thing that we do is automatic
paradism that gives you the way to
powerfully use all the par all the
parition pattern that you can use
without hard code them and uh one of the
thing that I want to emphasize is that
we are we are open system like Lego
braks that you can plug in into various
parts and plug other braks into into MX
mxet one important example is that
currently we it actually works as a
fully functioning torch module which
means that you can you can take any
function the in the torch and use that
mxet and it also balance the flexibility
of of the symbolic and of the declar
programming and imper programming to
gives you the maximum maximum
performance and the and the flex
ibility okay so I will hand over to Eric
for the next part of the talk thanks um
so TNT has talked a lot about MX design
and its cool features so hopefully by
now you're convinced that it's a good
system and now I'm going to talk about
how you can use it um so since it's a
fairly technical audience I will assume
knowledge of machine learning and uh
python and uh napai and such so uh we
actually do have other front langu front
end language rappers like uh Scala Julia
R and Etc but uh python is the most
supported and it's the language I use so
I'm going to give examples in
Python um so uh and by the way uh feel
free to interrupt me I know that some of
you may have played with mxnet already
um so uh if you have more you have
deeper questions you can interrupt me I
anywhere to ask um so first the symbolic
graph is a Mac working okay um so first
um mxnet is the Bas the basic usage is
symbolic graph and uh symbols are basic
units of computation and you can Define
symbols like this with with a function
call and a symbol has has input and it
has name and the number of parameters
like how many hidden units this fully
conect layer has for output um you can
we also provide this is like the cafe
layer and it's a uh course
granularity symbol we also PR provide
finer granularity symbols like plus
multiply and uh you can Define it with
the F fc1 +
one assigned to
fc2 so uh and that's actually executed
in the uh symbolic engine is not of just
a imperative Clause um and then graphs
are defined by composing symbols you
first uh have a x which is a variable
which basically serves as a placeholder
for your input data and then you feed it
through the network you have F connected
activation and
softmax and then this will give you a
network which can be instantiated with
memory to give an Executor and here we
use Simple bind which allocates all the
memory buffers for you you can also C
bind without the symol and provide your
own arrays as buffers and
gradients and uh everything that you
don't bind if you use the uh bind method
everything you don't bind won't be
computed um if they can be if it can be
admitted they won't be computed and like
if you don't b a gradient for array it
won't be computed and you won't be able
to see it so anything that you want as
output you have to bind
it um otherwise it will be optimized out
uh so after that these are basically
works pretty much like non array you
with some limited feature and uh you can
assign to the input which is the data
and then you do a forward and then do
backward so after after you declare a
symbol and then you do some imperative
soal imperative programming on those
symbols it's still declarative
programming right so because you still
you still program on the symbol yes so
it it cannot be called mixed program
it's still programming on the S uh well
so this is a symbolic graph here it's
bed and then you can go forward and
backward to it these are two blackbox
symbol computational graphs and in the
middle you can do anything you want with
it so the output array is just a ND
array and you can say take that feed it
to a
CRF and do some inference in the CRF and
then take the gradient back ter from the
CRF and then feed it to the backward you
can you can add arguments here that is
after you run forward means you ex you
call the executor to ex
yeah yeah so the in other Frameworks you
can also call F evolv or something to
get the values and then you can f that
those values into whatever the the
difference is that in most of Frameworks
after you call Evo you you get a Val and
you do need a you you do need imperative
GPU average to sport all all those
operations the second difference is that
all those operation you be paralyzed in
a sense
that in the existing framework all you
do is that you take that new and you do
the update but all those operation are
not paralyzed and they are not aware of
the dependency so so those imper part
are actually acted as a fragmented
bodies instead of whole piece so
basically in I think this is mainly just
a library function call in any language
well why is different well so basically
the
forward yeah it
pushes not really so uh the forward is
after you compile this graph the forward
actually pushes a whole bunch of
operations to the engine and then it
returns without waiting for them to
finish so you pushed a whole lot of
stuff in the into the engine and then
say the network has 10 the network has
10 branches and you have 10 outputs the
forward immediately returns and you
don't you can take each output and do
anything you want with it without
waiting for the other
nine you see what I mean in a sense that
all the things are automatically
paralyzed and excluded in a synchronized
man so that but that that is still that
paration still happens inside library
right no it's it's it's not happen so it
happens inside the function call as well
as outside function call so after you
call forward and backward you do a you
do a parameter update that parameter
update can be paralyzing together with
those forward and backward calls so as
soon as you get a gradient in backward
call the param will happen so that's the
major difference between like a Sero
execution and the automatic
paration but parition is still happen
inside your library right uh no it
happens in
Python it happen in Python uh well it
happens in the engine but it's issued in
you can issue everything in Python yeah
basically you issue everything in Python
in an imperative manner that's the
difference between so most libraries
allows you declare a graph and you you
do whatever paration optimization on
that graph but most Library doesn't
allow you to do parition over different
type of graph extion for example you
Exel graph get a gradient you do the
parent update that's a different
operation most Library doesn't allow
doesn't allow paration between those two
operations while because if you want to
really support imper operation well you
do want to be able to check all those
dependences and paralyze them paralyze
all those operations as a whole piece
because all all these operations are
also runs on GPU and they they need to
for example the parameter update need to
be done as soon as you get the gradient
in the backward St instead of waiting
all the backward step to finish so
basically here um you have these these
Network layers and each one has a few
parameters when you after you do a
forward you can do a backward pass
then it will since is this is a linear
structure you can it will execute from
this one to this one and then backwards
and uh the backward actually returns
immediately after it pushes all the
operations into the engine and then you
when you do the
update it your update you call update on
each parameter and uh if this is just a
normal function call you would need for
the backward to compute the gradient for
each of the parameters before you can do
update before it returns syn or not
uhhuh you can do a function called a
synchr that return iMed right uh yes
um yeah but then you need the dependency
engine so that so basically that's why
the dependency engine is good because it
it registers all the read and R
operations on each of the parameters so
you can issue everything without uh
waiting for anything to finish it will
get automatically dispatched when it's
ready to be
run but since since the computing
device is limited MH okay and uh when
you laun some computation on the
computer device that device is occupi
then you cannot another
so so based on that you have the
limitation of computing device the only
thing you can actually paralyze is the
memory copying and some commutation
right um so there are two cases so first
if your layers some your network has
multiple branches and some layers are
small running that layer doesn't occupy
the enti GPU then when you can if you
can run two branches in parallel it
gives you a speed up the other is this
extends naturally to multiple gpus you
can easily do model
parallelism across multiple gpus yeah
but we this in con this typically will
be slowed down your overall um Community
significant and every time when you copy
information between GPU devices or GPU
CPU well you you need to uh that's why
you need dependency
engines I mean depend itself is not
enough well you need a special model
structure for that not just dep oh well
yeah I know so basically if you just
take a vgg network and you put the First
convolution on one GPU and the second on
the other GPU it won't work very well
but if you have a more decoupled
structure will work better say these
days they have the two stream uh video
recognition network that has one
stream for uh for RGB the other for
optical flow and then the two stram
merge on the top then you can easily
parallelize the two part on two gpus
right but you still if you want to get
optimal speed up you still need to have
some human uh hint uh to to to decide uh
how you want to paralyze or where you
want to run each BR well you just need
to say which symbol should be allocated
to which device so you basically the
system you say which symbol goes to
which device okay then I don't see any
benefit other than parallel between
computation and the m c because you
still need to human uh to decide exactly
which one to Compu it's the same as
other to basally you can also do the
same
thing is that this is two separate
branches you can compute each one
independently on different gpus and then
just have a glue at the top so it's very
similar you can basically easily
Implement same thing on other to Cas
well yeah and but that requires manual
coding for each specific case and as
soon as you get to for gpus with with
crazy Network structures you you'll find
yourself writing like hundreds of lines
of code for for each specific network no
no no that's not true uh actually once
you have more than 4 gpus uh this kind
of oping typically will slow down your s
significantly well so that's why uh in
in in all our current implementation of
uh cross machine or cross GPU paration
we have some uh we need to use some
other techniques cannot just use uh in
your case this is per min bch ization
across multiple machines right M this
typically will be very
slow especially when you cannot increase
A Min size larger then this will be also
a problem so this
uh understand what you are talking about
now yeah so uh one thing is the Pascal
CPU gpus are coming out in probably half
a year if Nvidia up keep up their
promises and
uh they ad they advertise for like 10
times faster GPU to GPU
communication with NV link so I think
maybe it will probably get to a point
where inter GPU communication is similar
in speed to within GPU
communication because they have these 3D
memories for examp in your case we can
reduce memory cons
transfer by 32 times by quantizing the
gradient uh yeah well that even doing
that is not
enough you understand even chronization
by 32 times it's still not enough I
think it depends on your network
structure it depends on your application
for some applications it doesn't work
for someone it will yeah but but B yeah
for I understand what cuz you're saying
that data parm doesn't work and model
parm doesn't work in one bit grading
doesn't work what what thenon work no no
one one one bit one bit uh works if you
can increase a m b size to to very large
so nothing to do with their to Kit you
can choose any mini bat size you want
for any tool kit no no no no no if you
increase a mini bat size too large then
your final models performance is bad but
I don't see what this has to do with the
toolkit this toolkit supports model
parallelism data parallelism and you
know it can be one bit grad point I
don't see what no no what I mean see
what I mean that even one bit is not
involed said is as long as they can
improve the data transfer between GPU
and CPU it's enough I mean this is not
enough that's why we have some other
algorithms better than one bit
chronization to actually make this work
in in all those experiments we have
basically this kind of pro is not enough
this is what I want to yeah yeah don't
what don't want to see is that you need
to increase the minimum size dynamically
to saturate the communication channel so
that you can gain the benefit so this is
the whole point of like you need to
increase the Min size but yeah I have a
related question but actually I I'm
actually like the the dynamic uh
scheduling for for operations and for
memory but what concerns me actually is
the table that you had in in in in the
earlier part of the talk that you are
comparing your performance something
like torch okay so torch is is kind of
the the other side of of of the spectrum
where the researcher developer is like
building all this optimization by hand
and um the kind of the argument is tour
should offer the flexibility but maxnet
and other symbolic or like declarative
programs will will offer the
optimization yes but in these tables I
was I didn't see this huge difference in
terms of um speed UPS or memory this is
one part maybe because all these
networks are standard and everyone's
using cod in for example for convolution
and so on but the other part of the
question like like if you have some like
kind of um experiments like for
something like like like like like
machine translation models or like deep
lstm language models where you can do
model Paralis and show difference if you
have some benchmarks the the question
the other part of the question is if I
would do the the standard stuff all the
toolkits are the same but for the
nonstandard stuff maybe an imperative
program would be easier to work with
rather than a declarative program and if
the difference in in in speed and and
memory is not that big
anyways why should I go for declar
programs uh so uh basically uh the for
for the standard Pro for the standard
networks um people like uh people
working on Torch put a lot of
engineering efforts to optimize them and
uh so basically in the end they get to
the basically similar optimization as we
do here
automatically optimization uhhuh be
layer be operation optimization like
they have optim so like for example for
the rest NAD the the uh network is so so
big and so many layers that it doesn't
fit into memory and so what they did is
in the backward pass they take a
gradient blob and walk it down through
the network so that you don't need a
gradient blob for every layer we do this
automatically and we do many more
optimization for that but uh for torch
either you need to as a user you need to
code the optimization for each Network
you need to figure out what to do and
then you need the like uh sometimes
significant change to the infrastructure
to do that um
you certainly can but it's kind of too
much trouble otherwise you can also like
add a gazillion options to the standard
Library so that you can turn on each one
and turn on each optimization but like
it quickly becomes a manageable so so
this actually me kind of follow up
question so you're what you're saying
that for torch they did the coare what
you called coare by hand right yeah so
did you try to run reton the same kind
of uh
memor um uh with maxnet on the same kind
of
GPU um card with the same memory
limitation see if if your optim like
kind of automatic coare would uh would
would be runnable like or would it run
out of memory um I personally have
haven't and but we have people who
have the six it's the six G the six gig
card yeah so basic Bally we did we did
most of the memory sharing that you can
do automatically and uh so this requires
less effort when you are exploring new
network
structures your L layer is not separate
from the activation layer so that submax
output means subm loss and
activation yeah so then how easy it is
to change the loss to an arbitrary B
that we want to Define in MX um you can
do it with it depends on how complicated
your loss is um we have softmax
Activation so that's only the activation
instead of the activation with and loss
attached to it and uh you can do
anything on top of that by either
creating new symbols or composing
existing
ones
op question along that line so you
couple the soft Max activation and the
loss together so after you train a
motel how can you how can you you you
use the motel at desktop uh well at this
time you just don't call backrop and
then it will
work but even if you don't go backrop
you still call forward right for but
forward doesn't require label so so
that's a special symbol in forward it's
not output the loss function value it's
output the activation value actually so
it's like special casing for no so in
all of our output layers we don't output
the loss the loss is computed
separately and all these just output
whatever it's supposed to Output instead
of the
loss the loss is computed separately if
you want it in this how how can you
connect the gradient uh coming from the
loss to the to the model uh the gradient
actually doesn't come from the loss so
um imagine you are doing soft Max you
have
each each node you have a activation
right the gradient is just that minus
one right so it the gradient doesn't the
gradient doesn't require you to
explicitly compute the loss so yeah we
we don't you don't need
to but sometimes the L function might
impact the the way that you compute the
gradient well for for that layer you can
compute the
loss so it in this case you don't need
to so uh is there a way to if you wanted
to chain different graphs together
because like you wanted to do a dynamic
Network yeah exactly we're we're going
to talk about that in the following
slides
um
so uh I want to talk a little bit about
naming so in mxnet every symbol and
every array in the symbolic graph has a
name and the names are not arbitrary so
we have certain name conventions that
can impact
behavior um so you can create a variable
placeholder by declaring a
variable and uh all the other output
arrays and unnamed arrays un named input
arrays will be named by symbol
name and default array name um for
example fc1 weight fc1 output which
didn't appear in the previous slide they
will be allocate they will be named by
default um and in the default model and
updator
um you don't have to use this but if you
use just using standard fit for neur
Network probably this will make make it
much easier if you're using this all the
arrays that ends with weights will be
treated as weights there will be weight
decayed and initialized weights and the
biases will be initialized to zero and
won't be decade and
uh data blobs from the data iterator
will be copied to The Blob input arrays
with the corresponding name so uh these
are like variable names in your program
that it's not just for display it's not
arbitrary
um and so I just want to quickly mention
that IO in mxnet is different from
tensor flow and Cafe in that in tensor
flow and Cafe it's just a layer in their
graph it takes nothing and sped out data
data but here we separate the
computation graph from the data iterator
because we want to make the forward and
backward cleaner so that it acts as a
function that takes input and get sped
out output so uh these are actually
separated and during run time you you
will be copying the data into
the uh into the model the exe executor
and we provide a number of default
data iterators like ND array either
which allows you to use nonp arrays as
input and we also have image record edor
for image net and other image based uh
and we also have ammin dator and you can
easily create additional data iterators
in the front end language like in Python
by subclassing the base data iterator
class mhm do the data iterator support
suffing uh or do users have to Supple
the data
themselves well it does some local
shuffling but not Global ones because it
can be very in efficient on SSD so um
Doan so basically we take 1,000 examples
Shuffle that instead of take the whole
data set and do a complete
shavel uh
uh basically for this for this either
yeah it's also like a Rand Rand reading
of random blocks so that's a global
random block
shuffling so it's but it's not the
entire shuffling as you would do with a
one array because it can be very
inefficient for like HDD hhd diss
specific to just a few
iterators
every uh well so this is just in memory
so you can do any shuffling you want and
uh this is on disk so for large image
data set so we only do local shuffling
and blog shuffling um and this I think
is not shuffled because it's just a
example as like it makes it convenient
to show am minist results and when
you're are subclassing this and creating
your own data you can do whatever you
want but as a user how do I know which
generator
support software which one uh it's in
the document I think okay so by the way
um does it uh handles um sequences
nicely or not uh yeah recently we added
that we we do bucketing for
sequences uh which I will explain
shortly
um so after you have the data and the
graph you can train it pretty easily by
first creating a model object you
specify the context you wanted to run
now this is gpu0 you can fed an array
here gpu0 to GPU 4 and it will
parallelize that for
you
um you can also do so here is is a
example so if you use vgg or Google net
which especially Google net which has
very few uh few parameters but has a lot
of computation we on single machine with
four gpus we get uh basically linear
speed up with with modle
gpus um so and all those are just
automatic you don't you don't need any
coding for that um I will also cover
recurrent networks and more complicated
examples
later and uh so since mxnet will the
executor will op optimize everything out
if you don't need it this can make
debugging harder because sometimes when
your model are blowing up and you don't
know why you want to print the
intermediate gradients or weight arrays
during the training to see some of them
are doing weird things um to do that we
provide a monitor class that hooks into
the executor and the immediately after
each array is computed we push another
operation into it and saying that take
this array and compute some statistics
on that and return the statistics
so after you create a monitor say I
print every 10 batch with this statistic
function this is just a standard
deviation and uh I want to compute on
everything on every array that matches
this this is regular expression
matching and uh sort the result based on
name then you can find the executor and
install the monitor to it or you can
provide the monitor to the fit function
function and uh you will see these
statistics printed out every 10
batch question this so I think is very
important to for for this for a lot of
things so do do you all can I uh step
into to have some pre or whatever have
what examp if I I'm interesting certain
node and value so want look at it and
then print print the value and then you
have you have such well here you can
return arbitrary things and we will
print it for you so whatever here but
remember that this is pushed into the
engine so you cannot do aing you cannot
do blocking calls here so this just uh
do the basically any anything arism
computation just don't call as NP here
so basically don't take the don't take
the the array data and try to copy it to
the python front end it will be C copied
and printed later but don't copy it here
also if I want G and checking so uh so
you have code already yeah we we do have
GRE and
checking
um okay yeah so and also this does hurt
performance because you're Computing all
this stuff and it's blocking the uh
computation each step to compute this so
only use it when you need it and
probably set this to a bigger
value okay so uh we built mxnet with the
idea that it should be a open system
that's easily extend extendable so we
already have some examples of that we
can call torch uh tensor functions so
basically ones or SVD for all those
torch functions with MX in the arrays
and it's executed in the engine
asynchronously um so it's pretty
transparent it's as though you are just
using MXN own functions and we can also
integrate torch and N layer into MX
symbolic graph so you can take one torch
script that defines a layer it has
forward backward and grad gradient and
you can embed it into the m F maxnet
symbolic graph as one
symbol um this allows you to migrate any
existing work in torch you have to mxnet
pretty easily so basically when you
develop new algorithms you pretty much
Define a a set of new layers that you
want to use probably two or three you
can just put it into axet and uh you
won't lose any existing work and we are
also working on Cafe integration it's
harder because Cafe doesn't have a full
function scripting interface so we need
to fake Cafe headers and like compile
with it it's a lot of
hacking um but with torch and
potentially tensor flow it's pretty
easy because they have this scripting
interface um so here we show how you can
call torch Center functions they're
provided under mxnet doth model module
and you can create random arrays and you
can call aric operations on it and you
can create multiple ones and then do
arism computation on it and these are
all asnc so when you call this this
returns immedi immediately and uh all
the
execution happens in the engine you
force synchronization whenever you take
this output and try to get it to from
python as nonp
arrays
um so they just take a maxiz ND array
data structure which is similar to npy a
lot of time it can be used with nonp
arrays transparently as if they're nonp
arrays and uh all all of these are
pushed into the engine um here we show
how you can use TCH and layers as mxnet
symbols so basically these are just like
any
other any other symbols in mxnet you
have torch module for the normal layers
and you have torch Criterion for the
torch loss
layers
um so basically the Lua string is a
initializer that uh it's a Lua command
or function that returns a low object
representing a neuron Network
layer
um so after you construct this graph it
works pretty much the same as any other
MX net graphs but this allows you to
migrate in this thing work but since
torch is imperative we cannot do any uh
memory optimization with it so these are
not memory optimized anything will be
there and won't be freed
um unless you're only doing forward in
which case we know for certain that
you're not going to C backward on it
again and it will be
free um so uh if you can use mxnet layer
if you you don't
have MX layer for that code
towards um so here we show how you can
do custom Training Loop this is more
advanced like when you are doing
something other than fit forward your
networks say uh if you have a
convolutional fully convolutional
Network that operates
on on different size images and you want
to do the spatial pulling thing and
generate different number of output from
each batch uh you can do it with your
custom Training Loop and a basic Loop
basically looks like this you take a
symbol you buy find it to create an
Executor and then you take a data
iterator for the number of EO you reset
it and then en numerate batch from the
data iterator and for each batch you
load the data to the executor this is
basically a assignment a bunch of
assignments and then you call forward
and then
backward in the middle of the forward
and backward and before and up after you
can do anything you want with the
output um like using a CRF to it or take
this executors for forward output and
feed it to the next
executor's uh input and then call that
executor backward and feed the gradient
back to this executor backward as
argument here um this here it doesn't
have any arguments because the uh the m
nist neuron network has a lost layer at
the end so it doesn't need gradient
input and then how would you so does it
how does it know which ones are missing
from the uh is it basically the terminal
nodes in the graph like if it if it if
it tries to execute that and it's
missing it'll throw an exception at run
time or something like basically you
know what I'm saying like there's some
nodes that are you know in the dag like
there's some nodes that don't have any
uh in this in this scenario there's some
nodes that don't have any um don't have
any thing coming into them right but you
still and that's what you have to pass
in the partials with respect to that
output for those guys you well so here
the whenever you bind you will need to
provide any every input and the gradient
to that if you don't provide they will
be optimized out if it can I see if they
can
so uh if you don't provide a weight it's
pretty bad it's going to be a random
let's say the let's say you have a
softmax output or just let's say you run
a recurrent neural network over over a
sequence you take the final hidden State
and then you want to pass that as input
to another Network right then you need
to pass back the the gradient with
respect to that final hidden State what
where do you say that like where do you
tell the network hey I'm going to do
this like is it do you have to you have
to bind a variable to that final uh uh
the backward of the other executor will
give you grent for every input okay for
every input you require it to other will
be optimized out for the things you have
you can take that assign It To The Head
grad here you just you just and me the
first thing know that that one's missing
right because if you didn't provide that
there would you could so if if the the
final layer is not lost it will need
headr to backward if you don't provide
one it will throw an arrow so okay so it
assumes that that whatever the like in
in terms of the actual dag whatever the
final thing is is going to be the one
that's that you that you provided
to whatever you bu now is yeah so you
you need to specify which one you want
and then it will be the head grad and
then you need to assign to it okay so
are you uh overlapping the EO with the
the uh forward backward update somehow
uh or or you like stop each time it goes
a next uh is there like some internal
queuing of the iterator it's it's done
by depend on the so all these are
scheduled the forward will return
immediately and this will return
immediately and the updator also push
the computation of the momentum and uh
modify gr modify the weights and these
are also into the engine the only thing
that's synchronized is the metric update
because you need to compute the metric
and print it out so this is is
synchronized
and this is synchronized on the output
so it doesn't depend on the backward so
as soon as the operations in the forward
finishes this will return and then we'll
we will start the next patch so the
backward could be still running we are
already doing the for for the next patch
right right so so so when you are
blocked on update uh you're you're not
doing any IO
right to get the next
uh that's what iterator do it does
prefacing PR
yeah um do you have example of
the things that you put in the middle of
forward and uh not
in uh not in the slides okay uh uh it's
basically pretty easy you take these
outputs there these are just arrays and
you do what whatever you want with them
so that up is up from
for yeah and backward is uh
is these grad
arrays
um so uh as I said you can connect
multiple executors and uh you can insert
some imperative computation and uh we
also have data parallel executor manager
that allows you to easily do a data
parallelism across multiple gpus or
across multiple machines so do you have
a way to I'm interesting just look at a
particular uh frame uh you have that way
a
particular of particular frame so I'm
not interesting all the frames second
frame
so the
time so
you video stream
yeah stream so basically you don't find
whatever you don't need and they will be
optimized out if you need to compute
them and if you don't need to compute
them so if they are not in the middle of
other things you want you don't you just
don't compute them even for samples
inide well it depends on how you define
your graph structure basically it's a
dag whatever that you don't need say you
you you need the output here so whatever
that leads to here which is an output
that you don't need that this this
Branch won't be computed if you don't
find this so prob the question should
ask so if you have a sequence as aut for
example in the col networks you have
sequences um are you treat the whole
sequence as a unit or you treat each
sample as unit in your in your dat
well you can do
either so basically if you trade each
sample as a dag then you need to in
Python feed one to the to the next if
you bind them as entire deck then you
just take the input and then get the
output whatever that suits your
application so maybe uh so this will be
different for example uh if you Tre this
as a whole sequence mhm um in your whole
graph you probably only have for example
you have if you if you has use a uh
youur connecting at third layer thir
layer you can do BGE competition for the
lower layers and upper layers but not
that layer is this handled in your your
tool or
not I don't quite get what you mean so
that's a specific that you can write in
Python basically so you need to write
this in Python and do this uhing by
yourself basically if you if you need
that pattern no this is not because this
can be optimized inside anything but
you're not doing that right now right uh
what exactly can be
optimized so you are you have you're
saying you have a network uhhuh uh let's
consider the simplest Rec Network where
you only have a safe loop at the third
hidden layer if have hidden layers you
only have a s s recurrency at the third
of hidden layer uhhuh um if you treat
each sample as a independent stuff you
can you need to unroll the whole graph
into very big de uhhuh and you compute
each sample independently so you can
paralyze but each one is very small
commutation so typically very that's
where the dependency engine come in so
what I mean this is very slow a better
solution is to compute
everything below the third uh layer is a
a huge batch computation so it's very
efficient everything after above that is
also a whole batch also efficiency only
the third layer which has the recurent
connection you need to compute the
sample by sample this cannot be uh well
the symbolic graph doesn't enforce batch
size across symbols so you can change
the back batch size where wherever you
need and so the dependent the dependency
engine if you bind every executor for
each time step it won't it so the
forward will return immediately after it
push all the execution into the engine
and then you can directly use the output
although it's haven't been computed you
can directly use the output and feed it
to the next executor and the dependency
engine will schedule everything for you
and you don't need to do do any
synchronization manually I'm not talking
about synchonization we need to talk I
think this is too much of a subtlty I
know what you're talking about but I
think we it's it's a very subtle issue
that I think it's hard to explain
because unless you drew it out I think
it's I think we can talk about after
right we need to talk
this um so uh backing uh T already
talked a little about we how we are
doing marketing for uh uh variable lens
or size inputs so basically uh if you
have a fully convolutional neuron
Network on variable image sizes um for
example for image for detection um you
can allocate multiple executors and uh
have them share memory so that you you
are not going to
call them in parallel they
are they share memory and uh you your
cost uh your memory cost will be equal
to the
maximum cost of the maximum
executor
um you can have one executor for each
image size and uh you can cach them and
take whenever you get image you put it
into the
corresponding
executor question yeah what's the
overhead of spinning new executor uh if
you are sharing memory it's pretty fast
um we didn't do exact computation but
it's basically some Graph Search so
basically some DFS search on say 100 200
node
graphs we need to compute the dependency
structure no it's not ahead of time so
no for for each
executor if every mini batch have
absolutely a new uh size so you know two
mini batches share the same input size
you will need to create one for each but
isn't that usually the case where you
bucket a mini badge well you have you
have one bucket for each mini
bad well you have one bucket type for
each manyi batch but it's it's the cost
is done ahead of time so you define how
many buckets you have ahead of time and
then you then you sign it to one batch
but still it's a one time cost so it's
not really anything no but what youing
the computation do you do them
uh one by one or you do everything in in
in one batch in one k
operation well it depends on what you
want to do so one kernel fit forward
cannot operate on different sized images
right if you have within one batch
different image sizes you will have to
do the maximum you will have to make
make the batch the maximum size and then
pad the smaller images
because like GPU doesn't work that way
you you can't do the for do you do like
buck five or 10 right so yeah you can
assign images with Sim very similar size
to each batch and uh save some
overhead yeah actually in CN we group
everything together doesn't matter what
the size is so you can use Just Launch
as one actually uh do two CS one for
competition one for uh um post
processing but that that's only for the
speech cases no no no not just speech LC
uh well suppose you have two images one
is 400 by 800 one is 200 by 400 then
your kernel will need to operate on 400
by 800 you you can you can you can you
can add add stuff you can you can
basically you can do petting p stuff
yeah yeah that's what I'm talking about
so if you have images with variable size
in within a batch you have to P the
smaller images to the larger on yeah
this is what I ask you so are you doing
this together to batch uh as much s into
one uh col operation or you actually run
this as simple single operations
multiple times uh it depends on what
Behavior you want in Python so it can be
done within like 10 lines of python code
um depends on what you want if we find
that most people want some specific
thing we can add it to the
library so
um have a question
so so so we uh Jac also that so we have
this attention model the it's not only
the input that is variable then but Al
output is also variable then uh well it
so how do you do this uh it doesn't
matter each bucket only have a fixed
Network structure it has a fixed number
of input and output say your network can
be like 10 input 20 output five input 10
output you just create a bucket for each
possible case uh hopefully is that I was
the one who pushed for this that's why
I'm thank you guys for doing but uh is
that you can do any sort of weird graph
you want and it's just it's just a
disjoint graph right so you have so in
this case the attention graph says every
Target connects to every source and so
for the buckets from size 40 to 50 you
have a connect to you have this one
target connect to 50 things to the
bucket 3040 you have it connect to 40
things that's that's very difficult to
do in the style of uh of uh declarative
B like the cntk style where where you
don't explicitly unroll the loop because
um because then all of these cases like
one to many like it's fine for for like
for like for like feed forward and
bidirectional Al but once you have
things or something like let's say it's
a parse tree where for a s of length n
the actual graph is a parse tree a
complete binary par Tre of length uh 2N
right where it's it's the Parry building
up doing doing something like that in a
um in a in a simple like a language of
metal language saying how you want to
unroll it is is not really possible but
this method just lets you define this
graph this graph this graph in this
graph and then this is the one I
actually want to use at
one yeah so basically you can't have any
number of graphs and they can be totally
dis joined and they they just share GPU
memory and uh and there won't be any any
uh synchronization because they share
the same ND array and that's scheduled
by the engine so you don't need to wait
for one executor one bucket to finish to
start the next one you can just go ahead
and do
it um
so also uh if you find you in yourself
in need of new symbols that's not
present in mxnet you can create it in
multiple ways so first we have basic
arithm computations you can just
composing compost those and get your new
symbol or if that doesn't work or you
want more efficiency you can do a symbol
in C++ code by writing CA kernel or uh
we have this m Shadow with Library which
is similar to aen it's basically
templated Matrix library and you can
write those and it will be able to run
on CPU and
GPU
um you can also Define a symbol in front
end language in Python it's a little
less efficient but it's much easier to
write than than C++ and Cuda code you
can just just take the ND arrays and uh
get nonp arrays to Python and do
whatever you want on it and then feed it
back um we also support writing Cuda
kernels in front end with Nvidia runtime
compilation so Nvidia has a NV RTC
library that allows you to compile
kernels run time and we can compile
kernels for ND arays
runtime um
so uh we also support writing layers in
Lua with torch and then Co it from torch
module so uh there are a number of ways
you can do
it and uh thank you so that's my
thought